people can you please not bring your
guns into chipotle that's what they're
requesting after a bunch of guys carried
military-style assault rifles into a
Chipotle franchise in dallas texas they
were promoting their open carry laws
because you're allowed to if you have a
gun you're allowed to openly exhibit it
and bring it around into public spaces
but chipotle would just prefer you not
do that they even issued a statement the
display of firearms in our restaurants
has now created an environment that is
potentially intimidating or
uncomfortable for many of our customers
of course it went on to go on and on and
say you know so please don't bring guns
into chipotle will give you the
guacamole but we're gonna charge you
extra they make a big point of that
really make another extra yeah like I
know it's guacamole we're done it's
guacamole it's not free this is America
nectar of the gods I understand it's
gonna be at a previous yeah so these
people that are bringing the guns there
these are assault rifles these are not
just the I'm not just a handgun at a
fast food joint azir assault rifles but
they have a right to do it so before we
get jokey and Libya about them should we
defend their right to bring their
weapons did you bother I mean you know
I'm slightly intimidated by saying you
know I don't know if somebody's gonna
come out and like you know pull their
weapons on me cuz good lord reading all
the comments underneath these articles
there is a large amount of people who
really want that second amendment
amendment upheld Jesus um you know I
think that there needs to be some type
of parameters set though you know it's
not like like can I just push like my
canon in through the door but like just
saying this is busy you know I'm here to
openly carry I'd like a burrito my canon
one for me and one for my cat yeah and I
feel really bad for the you know burrito
wrappers that need to come out and you
know calmly ask Billy Bob to like put
their assault weapon back in the truck
like it just doesn't seem like a fair
pairing but yeah so if you went into
chipotle and there was two guys sitting
there with assault rifles on the table
what would you do well I went to Costa
Rica to a pizza hut and there was a guy
outside with an assault rifle and it
freaked me the hell out but he was just
grr yeah he was just a guard and he had
an assault rifle I I get it I mean yes
these are it's tough when it's like the
way in which you display your right is
really scary yes you know that's what
everyone's afraid of and I think they
should solve this all by having
different kinds of Chipotle's there's
chipotle where you can't have guns and
then there's Chipotle's where you can
only have guns and there's like an all
gun chipotle like a battle royale
chipotle listen well I like the normal
cheapo like they have they'll have these
ones that have only everyone has a gun
and then the normal Chipotle's where
they have that trademark chipotle knife
fight every so often right so basically
in the south that's where the gun ones
are the knife fights we're gonna be like
oh there's lots of guns in all kinds of
cities i feel like people you know I
just I just want I you know it's that I
I want them to be able to have their
right on display but I mean it's weird
where you gonna put your assault rifle
in the car outside I mean you want it
with you you know what someone's
stealing that yeah it's part of the
problem though that when we have these
talks about guns that the comments
section always it's everyone demanding
their right that they immediately if you
even talked about this and say that
maybe you shouldn't be allowed to bring
an assault rifle into chipotle they
immediately take that as they're coming
for our like it quickly they can refuse
your service if you have no shirt and
knows you got exactly but if you're
carrying your assault rifle with no
shirt no shoes maybe they'll have till
are you and now i don't know i mean i
think that there needs to be a balance
ahead which is you can carry a concealed
weapon which would make sense you know
you have it on you still why do you need
to avoid you laughing around i just
don't understand yeah yeah well penis
thing right at the end of the day as
yeah no joke goes it's a small base yeah
that an issue for me at least right so
this is my yes my video I look at you in
small penis and for you this is really
an anti he knows my Venus is mighty I
think we finished take it is there any
bring us home here I do I
a long as I can still get diarrhea
chipotle which happens all the time
really I love Chipotle yeah yeah look I
like I have to poop other thing I just
swallowed like that's how far I should
see a guy right chipola is like the four
seasons yeah Mexican food I don't know
it's just like so spicy some of this
stuff is just so spicy try the mild so I
know they always get like a little tiny
thing a jalapeno in there and it lates
your face on fire all right we're gonna
go to chipotle one of these days we'll
help with your order okay we'll go from
there we're not gonna besmirched
chipotle on this show